Salve! Ecco qui, ecco.
*sfondo di Yew Nork*
Era abbastanza a sorpresa, eh?
- Non me l'aspettavo.
- Eh, hai visto? Fra un po' esce Endgame. Sapete qual è la cosa bella di vivere nel mio cervello?
È che io sono staccato dalla maggior parte delle cose. Io guardo le cose da fuori. Per esempio, del Marvel Cinematic Universe io non sono appasionato.
Ma mi piacciono I film action. Il problema del Marvel Cinematic Universe è che a un certo punto mi sono rotto i coglioni,
e so per certo che un sacco di altra gente la pensa così.
Poi voglio dire, sono fumetti, roba per bambini, no?
Tutti i registi di film di fumetti son tutti rincoglioniti, i disegnatori di fumetti non fanno un vero lavoro.
Però poi cosa succede?
Succede Infinity War, succede che un film è effetivamente bello ed effetivamente spettacolare,
e due ore e mezza, due ore e quaranta di film volano via come se fossero dieci minuti.
Ma un sacco di gente non l'ha visto perché si è rotta il cazzo prima. Siccome arriverà Endgame,
e sicuramente sarà bello perché è il seguito di Infinity War, vi riassumo io tutto il Marvel Cinematic Universe,
io che sono una persona a cui gliene frega relativamente:
non sono fan della Marvel ma mi piacciono i film di merda action trash, infatti uno dei miei registi preferiti è Michael Bay.
L'ho detto non, non fare facce, non annui-
Quindi vi riassumo io con tanto di set e props che vedrete
tutto il Marvel Cinematic Universe in modo che voi possiate non farlo.
- Ho sputato tantissimo tutto il tempo.
- L'attacco su New York più strano che abbia mai visto.
"I R O N M A N"
La particolarità di questi film, di tutti i film del Marvel Cinematic Universe è che hanno una marea di attori guest star famosissimi,
ogni singolo film, è incredibile. Per esempio in questo c'è Jeff Bridges
...ma perché?
In questo film Robert Downey Jr. - ve lo ricorderete perché è quello che prima del Marvel Cinematic Universe si drogava e andava in prigione -
diventa ricco, lo rapiscono gli arabi, ma siccome lui è molto molto ricco e molto molto intelligente riesce a scappare...
...dentro una caffettiera,
𝙴 𝙶𝙻𝙸 𝙰𝙼𝙴𝚁𝙸𝙲𝙰𝙽𝙸 𝚅𝙸𝙽𝙲𝙾𝙽𝙾.
"hulk​"
Io non sono sicurissimo che questo film conti per davvero però
C'è Edward Norton che fa Hulk, e poi cambia.
e c'è Tim Roth nel film, e c'è Hulk e un altro mostro che fa Tim Roth, e si picchiano
fortissimo e poi vince.
"Iron Man 2". C'è Mickey Rourke a Monte Carlo che si vuole vendicare di Iron Man e lo mena con due fruste elettriche
su una pista di Formula 1, non so... Tra l'altro in questo film c'è War Machine che
è cambiato ed è più nero del primo film non si sa perché.
"Thor"
C'è Anthony Hopkins, io non ho idea di come facciano a prendere questi attori...
- Li pagano.
- Li pagano, giustamente.
E anche Natalie Portman che, voglio dire poi, Anthony Hopkins era anche in Transformers quindi voglio dire, c'è Thor che viene
scaraventato sulla terra perché è una testa di cazzo
fondamentalmente, perché non è degno, poi durante il film ridiventa degno e il film finisce. Alla fine del film arriva Samuel L. Jackson,
che è Nick Fury, che recluta tutti gli Avengers piano piano
"Capitan America". C'è una specie di bobble head di Chris Evans,
non so se... ha un effetto speciale della merda dove lui è super magro ma ha una testa gigantesca, però poi fortunatamente
lo sostituiscono con il vero Capitan America, e nel film ci sono sia Tommy Lee Jones
sia Hugo Weaving, e tra l'altro Hugo Weaving fa la parte del nemico di Capitan America,
Teschio Rosso. Il film è pieno zeppo di nazisti, e gli americani vincono!
Le cose fondamentali del film sono due. Uno, è che Teschio Rosso viene
sparato nella stratosfera ed è molto importante a quanto pare, per qualche motivo, tipo il Team Rocket che fallisce la missione
ma soprattutto viene introdotto in questo film
il Tesseract, te l'ho detto che non ne valeva la pena
"Avengers". È invecchiato veramente male, sembra un film degli ultimi anni '90 circa, ma magari è fatto apposta
- E qui bene o male ci sono tutti quanti, tutti quanti gli Avengers.
- Che distruggono New York.
- Giustamente.
Che lottano contro... dov'è? Loki, eccolo qui, e Loki
fa arrivare delle creature orripilanti su degli skateboard fatti di non so che cazzo siano, di tecnologia, con dei vermoni
enormi, ma gli americani vincono!
La cosa importante è che Tony Stark
va nello spazio, o lo spazio va da lui come Maometto
va nello spazio e, cosa molto importante,
si vede Thanos
nella classica posa del "ho fatto gol" per la prima volta, e qui tra l'altro finisce la prima fase
del Marvel Cinematic Universe, siccome state guardando questo video perché ve ne sbatte i coglioni faccio a meno di dirvelo
"Iron Man 3". Qui ci sono delle turbe brutte brutte che tornano in testa a Tony Stark. Il
cattivo in questo film è un nemico che si chiama il
Mandarino ma il colpo di scena, che è quello che ha fatto anche
rompere il cazzo tutti quelli che sono andati al cinema a vederlo è che in realtà il Mandarino non è veramente il Mandarino
in realtà il vero nemico è Guy Pearce, non so quanti soldi abbiano per riuscire a prendere questi attori però, sì
"Thor 2". Questo è un film di merda, detto da tutti, è un film di merda, inutile, brutto,
inutilmente costoso e fa cagare ma incredibilmente ha un voto più alto su Rotten Tomatoes di Bohemian Rhapsody, e che ci vuoi fare?
In questo film appare per la prima volta la prima Gemma dell'Infinito, rossa, che sparirà a breve
"Capitan America: The Winter Soldier". Qui c'è Capitan America che picchia fortissimo
il suo ex migliore amico, un po' come Pretty Little Liars,
che diventa immediatamente cattivo, vedi? Così, e nel film c'è Robert Redford... io... e niente
e, per la prima volta in tutta la saga, una trama.
"Guardiani della Galassia". Nel montaggio,
probabilmente lo vedrete, metterò un sacco di luci e colori strobo e gli anni '80, e la musica degli anni '80
perché alla gente piace, e qui
presentano tra l'altro i personaggi più
interessanti, diciamo, dicono che sia uno dei film più belli
del Marvel Cinematic Universe, e ci sono come vedete, questa squadra nello spazio tipo Power Rangers in Space, che sono
quello con la maschera, She-Hulk,
l'albero quello del Signore degli Anelli, poi purtroppo io ho comprato i set,
i playset della Disney e c'era il playset dei Guardiani della Galassia ma dentro non c'erano né Rocket Raccoon e né
Bautista. Ho dovuto
farmeli io
questo, Bautista, si legge The Animal sulle mutande, grazie mille.
"Avengers: Age of Ultron"
Questo film qui
è girato in Valle d'Aosta. Qui c'è una cazzata incredibile: c'è Tony Stark che crea un robottone
che gli si rivolta contro
e tra l'altro si ricarica via USB, è una roba
terribile,
però è così, che ne so, questi son della Marvel, lo sapranno. E tra l'altro ci sono due mutanti in questo film ma che
per i diritti della Fox non possono chiamare mutanti e quindi li chiamano
Qualcos'altro li chiamano...
e qui nasce un altro personaggio molto importante:
Visione. Visione nasce come la banana Chiquita, con la
pietra dell'infinito, verde se non mi ricordo male, in testa, eccola qui
- Era gialla.
- Era gialla, vedi? Introduciamo
Quicksilver e Scarlet che, ovviamente nel pack
della Disney non c'erano, quindi immaginateveli: una ha i capelli rossi, l'altro è super velocissimo ed è
talmente veloce Quicksilver che viene crivellato e muore nel film.
La cosa bella, non so se lo sapevate: i due attori che fanno Scarlet e Quicksilver, che sono fratelli,
nel film sono gli stessi attori che nel film di Godzilla sono marito e moglie
"E chissenefrega?". Eh va beh, eh scusate, era una curiosità.
Ma alla fine, la cosa più importante: Thanos prende il Guanto dell'Infinito.
È una presina da cucina e c'era un cartellino con scritto "non avvicinare a fonti di calore":
una presina.
"Ant-Man"
Te l'ho detto che nella nostra testa era molto meglio. C'è un uomo
piccolissimo in questo film vestito da formica che lotta contro un altro uomo
piccolissimo vestito da calabrone. C'è uno degli effetti speciali più belli della storia del cinema ed è sulla faccia di Michael Douglas.
Il film a livello di trama è tipo "Una promessa è una promessa",
mischiato a "Tesoro, mi si sono ristretti i ragazzi", con un pizzichino di "A Bug's Life"
Ah! Mi stavo dimenticando...
"Capitan America: Civil War"
Non so perché questo non sia "Avengers 3"
ma sia "Capitan America: Civil War" e quindi
"Capitan America: Civil War". È il film di Capitan America ma ci sono tutti quanti e tra l'altro è la prima volta che si vedono
Black Panther e Spider-Man, definito da tutti "Preferivo Tobey Maguire!"
"Dottor Strange"
Inizia che praticamente è una puntata di "E.R."
Poi lui, se vedete qui, si fa male alle mani, va da uno di quei santoni di "Striscia la Notizia" ma a sto giro
funziona incredibilmente il santone e lui diventa... c'ha i poteri, poi diventa un po' "Inception" anche, un pochino, c'è come nemico Mads Mikkelsen
lottano come in "Inception" e muore e lui vive e vince, e qui appare la Gemma dell'Infinito verde
Ci siete? Per ora ci siete? Perfetto.
"Guardiani della Galassia 2".
- Groot però è quello piccolo.
- Quello piccolo?
- Sì.
- Eh non c'era.
Ci sono loro
e c'è lui che ha problemi con suo padre, col padre
di Star-Lord ci sono problemi gravi e tra l'altro il film ed è talmente inutile che...
"Spider-Man: Homecoming". Pensa,
non uno, ma due costumi di Spider-Man c'erano, ma non Rocket Raccoon e Bautista dentro... e non lo so perché. E comunque preferivo Tobey Maguire!
E finalmente nel sesto film di Spider-Man non muore zio Ben
C'è Peter che va in gita scolastica e viene attaccato da Michael Keaton,
quello di "Birdman", come vedete qui nella sua rappresentazione in "Birdman", e c'è anche
Iron Man.
"Thor 3". È quando ho capito che non sono fan della serie perché a me è piaciuto un sacco.
Boom! Ci sono Thor, ci sono Hulk,
tra l'altro nella versione Planet Hulk, quello l'ho letto il fumetto, me lo ricordo, infatti è stato figo da vedere. Si menano anche se sono
amici, ci sono - haha - un sacco di risate
perché non volevano più farli
drammatici perché hanno visto che i film della DC drammatici facevan cagare la merda e quindi han detto facciamolo super funny perché "i Guardiani
della Galassia, te lo ricordi quello li no?
Tunz tunz anni '80? Ha fatto molto successo, invece questo no, e mortacci vostra perché a me è piaciuto e c'è Cate Blanchett come nemico? Ok...
In questo film distruggono tutto, arriva il Ragnarok, distruggono Asgard
ma poi va tutto bene. C'è Idris Elba
prima che la gente sapesse chi fosse, ma soprattutto
incontrano Thanos.
"Black Panther". C'è Batman
Straight Outta Wakanda! Batman diventa re, ammazza Creed
e vince, e decide di aprire i porti tra l'altro
97% su Rotten Tomatoes. Non capisco un cazzo io a quanto pare di film
Sette premi Oscar, e ne ha vinti tre! E poi
Indovinate chi è Martin Freeman nel film.
"Infinity War". I Vendicatori fanno di tutto per impedire a Thanos di schioccare le dita
ma lui le schiocca comunque.
E gran finale
però poi hanno fatto altri due film dopo quindi devo ricostruire il set adesso, un attimo solo
"Ant-Man 2". Il film è
completamente inutile
però lui
rimane bloccato nel mondo quantico e io non ho un set del mondo quantico perché non so come sia fatto
però è importante questa cosa qua perché probabilmente ciccerà fuori per Endgame e salverà tutti.
"Capitan Marvel"
Ho anche Capitan Marvel, la versione del fumetto ma ho anche Capitan Marvel. Fate finta che questi siano Kree. È
fortissima viene
addestrata dai Kree, che sono poi quelli di Secret War, di Secret Invasion,
non mi ricordo, va beh uno dei due, voi andate a cercare, però lei è in realtà
umana, colpo di scena è umana che ha il potere di una Gemma dell'Infinito che è di colore...
- Giusto, l'unica che manca è...
- È il Tesseract.
Ci sono delle battute terribili sul fatto che sia una pastiglia della lavastoviglie, della
lavatrice, con la povera Capitan Marvel però... si scopre che Jude Law è il cattivo.
Come? Fino all'ultimo. E c'è
Samuel L. Jackson, super ringiovanito anche lui, solo che come lo ringiovanisci lui? Gli togli le rughe, perché non ha capelli
- Ha i capelli.
- Ha i capelli, eh giusto, glieli mettono, eh giustamente. E a quanto pare
il twistone è che non è Capitan Marvel, non sono i Kree, non è il Tesseract e non è Samuel L. Jackson che vincerà
la Marvel, ma chi vincerà tutta la guerra
Spoiler.
E quindi eccoci qui: vi ho riassunto il Marvel Cinematic Universe in poche parole e da uno a cui non gliene frega molto del
Marvel Cinematic Universe ma semplicemente un appassionato di film action io non vedo l'ora effettivamente che crolli New York e esca Endgame
però non, cioè a me dispiace che gente come me che ad
un certo punto ha detto "Basta, mi sono rotto i coglioni di vedere film di supereroi con la tutina",
però in realtà magari con "Infinity War" vi siete persi dei gran bei film secondo me quindi
non fate come me, non siate coglioni come me, io vi ricordo che ho
30 anni, 31
quest'anno, questo...
quindi
Boh ciao!